how would you like some easy tips based
on science and the science is on how to
be more productive creative or even
happier the nonprofit character lab
released an easy tip of the week every
week that aims to do just that their
goal is to build strength like gratitude
and honesty and they range from
everything like embracing the so-called
ikea effect to talking to yourself and
believe it or not that's apparently not
a bad thing they're all aimed at helping
families thrive angela duckworth is the
founder and ceo of character lab and
author of the best-selling book grit the
power of passion and perseverance she's
also a professor of psychology at the
university of pennsylvania and she's
here in the studio with us good morning
good morning thank you for having me
good to see you so let's talk about this
um you say it's important for us to talk
to ourselves why sounds crazy right
but i love that angela because i talk to
myself all the time
and i think is it like inner monologue
yes
about almost everything that i do and i
and i've often wondered if that's common
or uncommon you are a human all all
people talk themselves whether our lips
are moving or not we have this ongoing
inner monologue and and sometimes that
inner monologue says things like i'm so
stupid i can't believe i i messed that
up or nobody likes me
that kind of self-talk sometimes called
chatter is really unhelpful and if you
think about kids one of the things that
we can help kids do is learn how to
master self-talk in other words what are
ways that we can talk to ourselves more
productively so that silent monologue
could say things and here's this trick
that i don't think most parents are
going to figure out for themselves
research shows that if i say instead of
ugh i'm terrible i'm having a bad day i
say in the kind of talking to myself as
if i am a friend angela angela
that this is a bad day
angela what is there something that you
could do that would make this day better
in other words you change the self-talk
and in fact in a way you kind of use the
second person you say to yourself like
you know angela you're having a bad day
instead of oh i'm having a bad day
because i'm no i was gonna say the
reason i think that's it's really
interesting is because you also talk
about venting and i had that inner
monologue when
i'm about to vent or about to get on a
soapbox about something i say to myself
what would this do
there's the philosophy of the stoics
which says that you know you're
expending energy on something that is
not productive venting is not productive
so here's again where science i think is
is the big leap forward you know the way
that we were raised by our parents uh
you know who i sure did their best job i
think one major change is that we now
have science that says for example the
intuition that many parents have that
venting is a good thing science now
shows it's not a good thing when i come
out to a friend and i just let it all go
my anger just gets actually bigger not
smaller in other words vending doesn't
you know cure your bad moods it actually
tends to to feed them so you have this
thing called the ikea effect what is
that and all of the research on
character lab is but done by really
truly world-class scientists actually
most of it not by me because i'm not a
specialist in everything the ikea effect
is done by researchers including mike
norton at harvard that shows that if a
child or an adult puts effort into
something so you know you're building
your own stool or coffee table from ikea
and i actually experienced this myself
building a little stool my husband came
home and i was like this is a
masterpiece and he was like the the
stool and i was like yeah isn't it
beautiful look at the lines it's great i
gotta love sitting in the stool now he
didn't feel the same way because he
hadn't put the effort into the building
of it and i think in the time of screens
that you know you were just talking
about and the time of like one-click
shopping and convenience where kids have
more and more done for them to harness
the ikea effect the question is can can
they make their own breakfast can they
make their own handmade card to give to
somebody for a birthday that actually
makes people value
the product much more than if it were
given to them i'm hoping you can touch
on the danger of small lies but before
you do that with venting if you don't
vent what do you do when you have a you
know you feel like a volcano with
frustration coming out of your head yeah
and i do want to say that children and
adults we do need to feel seen and heard
so if you are having a bad day it's not
the worst thing in the world to express
yourself but really just letting it spin
out and kind of you know getting into a
spiral of you know more and more emotion
going you know
who knows where it's going to go i think
that one thing that all psychologists
would agree on is that what we need in
those moments of emotion is some
perspective so one thing you can do is
choose the right person to talk to
somebody who's gonna not just like feed
your fire and you know pile but but
actually say you know that's really
important that you feel that way what i
hear you saying is this but then also
you know the kind of person we have
these people in our lives were like yeah
that person's calm and they have
perspective when things are going out of
control so that's that's like one
practical thing yes talk to people but
maybe talk to the people who are going
to help broaden your perspective as
opposed to like suck you in uh so that
you know everything gets magnified all
right that's good advice i'm going to
use that
you don't strike me as a vendor i'm not
a villain whether there's a lot of
evidence to me and this is actually like
you know the perspective component
sometimes like it could be worse and
she's like i don't need to hear that i'm
like well but it could it could be worse
all right angela duckworth thank you
very much appreciate you being here